[موسيقى] الأجانب
يفضلون نطقها على أنها
قيثارة ممتازة أحيانًا ، لقد سمعت أيضًا
الحضيض ،
لكن بالتأكيد لا يوجد قاطع ،
لا بأس ، أعلم أن الناس لا
يخطئون في نطقها كما تعلمون على أنها وقحة
، بل إنهم لا يفعلون ذلك  أعلم
آمل أن يعرفوا اليوم
أولاً وقبل كل شيء أنه النطق الرسمي ،
لذا فهو إشارة قوية والطريقة التي
تقوم بها هي بمحاولة إغلاق
حلقك وهو T قوي والذي يكون تقريبًا
بين T و A D
ولكن بعد ذلك  إنها حرف R مدرفلة ، وهذا
سيكون صعبًا لأن
هذه الأحرف الثلاثة لا تُستخدم في
اللغة الإنجليزية ، لذا فإن
الطرق الأخرى المقبولة للقول بأن قطر هي
قطر مرحب بها في قطر ، لكننا
بالتأكيد لسنا غيتارات ولسنا
في الحضيض
بغض النظر  حول كيفية نطق أي شخص لأي
شيء ، تعتمد ثقافتنا كلها على
النية إذا كانت لديك نوايا حسنة ،
فنحن سعداء